mich hat heute bewegt friedrich merz
oder besser gesagt friedrich tritt mein
kollege ralf schuler der auch heute
abend in der sendung ist hat nämlich
herausgefunden
friedrich merz möchte es noch einmal
versuchen spiels noch einmal friedlich
so zu sagen er möchte noch einmal
versuchen cdu-vorsitzender zu werden
aber unter einer bedingung dass diesmal
nicht die sogenannten eliten abstimmen
dürfen nicht die delegierten nicht die
idee auskommen vorher wie können wir
friedrich merz verhindern sondern die
basis der partei das ist seine
bedingungen wie wir aus einem aller
engsten umfeld wenn die basis der partei
abstimmen darf dann wird er sich ein
drittes mal zur wahl stellen ein drittes
mal versuchen dass er die ersten zwei
male nicht geschafft hat nämlich
vorsitzende der partei zu werden warum
finde ich das gut weil es genau der
denkzettel ist den es jetzt gerade
frauen die wahl ist für die cdu so
verheerend schief gegangen weil man zu
viele entscheidungen den zu kleinen
gremien getroffen hat die mit der
realität im land rein nichts rein gar
nichts mehr zu tun haben mein liebstes
beispiel am ende haben volker bouffier
und wolfgang schäuble unter sich
ausgemacht dass armin laschet für die
cdu in den bundestagswahlkampf zieht
zwei hoch verdiente politiker mit großer
lebenserfahrung aber auch zwei männer
die zusammen 150 jahre alt sind und über
die zukunft der cdu entscheiden sollten
dass das schief gehen musste war klar
und deswegen von friedrich merz aus
meiner sicht das richtige zeichen lasst
die basis darüber entscheiden sie
versteht manches besser als die eliten
und dick regierung nun kann man ja über
friedrich merz denken was man will alle
reden über erneuerungen aber keiner
fängt an friedrich merz hat immerhin
eine debatte darüber angestoßen wie man
künftig den spitzenkandidaten aus
würfeln sollte und da ist in deutschland
doch eine ganze menge staub auf den
prozess drauf wenn man sich anguckt wie
in amerika die vor wahlkämpfe geführt
werden wie sich leute ausgleichen
parteien gegenseitig beharken im dienste
der sache damit am ende wirklich der
beste der eloquente der tapferste
durchkommt peter gauweiler hat seit
jahren korpus ist für deutschland
gefordert will natürlich keiner weil die
deutsche politik sich lieber im bequemen
einrichtet das ist eine wichtige debatte
und friedrich merz könnte der anlass
dafür sein zu sagen okay nicht unbedingt
mitgliederbefragung allein sondern auch
auftritte in der öffentlichkeit sich
durchbeißen und das finde ich eine gute
idee ja und vor allem wer ist eine gute
absicherung gegen das debakel was die
cdu jetzt gerade an aber er ist ja teil
des debakels also er ist zwei mal
angetreten als cdu-vorsitzender erst
zweimal es nicht geworden und das wird
gerade beschrieben wird aus dann wurde
er nicht aufgestellt als spitzenkandidat
stand er hat er die wahl verloren
zweimal aber warum ist der anteil des
debakels er hat ja einen anderen weg
alleine zeigt und die cdu hat die nicht
angenommen ja aber er war im
zukunftsteam er hat eine große bühne im
wahlkampf er stand hinter laschet er
wurde mit ihm assoziiert er war gegen
söder also das heißt die menschen
wussten wenn ich laschet wähle kriege
ich auch merz und sind trotzdem nur 24
prozent der cdu gegeben also für mich
ist es der falsche einheit dessen pflege
dieser debatte ich finde gerade aus dem
grund berliner den gerade angesprochen
wäre märz der richtige weil merz hat
gezeigt dass er ein teamplayer ist merz
hat kein ego zurückgestellt hat sie auch
hinter laschet gestellt hingegen hat
markus söder eigentlich die ganze zeit
nur gegen laschet geschossen und ich
finde märz hat gezeigt dass er sich mehr
zurücknehmen kann und das war zu dem
zeitpunkt richtig ob er den wahlkampf so
gefühlt hätte wie laschet nein er hat es
ja auch von der einstellung her schon
anders ich glaube dass es gut wäre um
die union wieder mehr konservativ zu
hause werden was wir dann wäre aus
seiner sicht die richtige debatte die
die cdu jetzt will sollte die kosten
verteilt obwohl man die wahl verloren
haben bestimmt nicht aber anerkennen wir
haben die wahl verloren
jetzt ist einfach auch grabmal nicht
daran dass die bild schlagzeile ist merz
möchte cdu-vorsitzender werden also das
ist so das letzte was deutschland grad
interessiert wer gerade cdu-vorsitzender
werden will also deswegen finde ich
jetzt geht in die opposition nutzt die
zeit der erneuerung wenn er sagt man
kann sich nur eine regierung irgendwie
neu erfinden ja dann hättet ihr
irgendwie in anderen wahlkampf machen
müssen aber jetzt habt ihr das was er da
habt die 24 prozent und jetzt ist es mal
gut jetzt interessiert mich gerade
klappt die ampel wer wird das kabinett
aber mich interessiert gerade nicht mehr
cdu pur also du gehst fest aus von
opposition und lampe absolut das ist
auch zumindest das was ich glaube 76
prozent der deutschen wollen olaf scholz
als kanzler die spd hat die wahl
gewonnen das ist ja auch das was jetzt
diskutiert werden müsste natürlich also
weiß ich ganz spannend finde es
tatsächlich dass gerade ein friedrich
merz ja so ein bisschen das
unternehmerische mut prinzip verfolgt
von trial and error trial and error
vielleicht kommt irgendwann auch treuen
ins taxi wir werden sehen fakt ist aber
dass die idee einer urwahl total
spannend ist und endlich mal alle
mitglieder mitzunehmen weil ich glaube
dass fehlt einfach und das ist natürlich
immer basisdemokratisch find ich absolut
richtig und was definitiv passieren muss
ist dass die union endlich mal in die
ruhe kommt weil gerade wenn man
verhandeln will finde ich braucht man
ruhige farbe total aber wenn das das
richtige ist basisdemokratisch den
cdu-vorsitz und warum haben sie es denn
nicht gemacht man kann ja du hast auch
um ein kernargument hier na ja das bei
der spd
derjenige des bundeskanzler geworden ist
der basisdemokratisch abgelehnt worden
ist ja also auch da kann man ja durchaus
dann zweifel daran haben ob das modell
funktioniert wenn derjenige den die
partei ausdrücklich nicht wollte im
ganzen land dann offenbar ja immer noch
so gut ankommt dass der bundeskanzler
werden werden kann aber das problem war
ja bislang das ist bei friedrich merz
zweimal ein relativ einhelliges
meinungsbild an der unions basis gegeben
hat für sein zu seinen gunsten auch
draußen im lande war er der beliebtere
und trotzdem hat eine leicht funktion
erst dominierte parteitags mannschaft
dann beschlossen das ist uns alles zu
unsicher dann räumt ja am ende wieder
auf und dann wird im haus wieder alles
auf den kopf gestellt dazu ich mal eine
frage an dich aber an die ganze runde
kann sich einer von euch erklären darin
liegt ja ein bisschen auch sozusagen das
ungemach dass die cdu jetzt bei der wahl
erlebt hat wie man darauf kommen konnte
dass es besser ist als
parteivorsitzender zu wählen als
friedrich merz hätte da nicht klar sein
müssen wenn wir die krankheit die
schlechteste rede seines lebens also aka
das beste und seine schlechteste anders
gleich hat sich nochmal bei laschet
gegen ihn wiederholt dass laschet einen
rausgehauen wie noch nie zuvor und
ehrlich also ich frage mich eher warum
ist ja in den entscheidenden momenten
dann nicht da und weil ich mich auch
frage will er wirklich jetzt gerade
cdu-vorsitzender oder ist das eine
schlagzeile die ihr jetzt gerade macht
weil das trend jetzt auf twitter ich
habe vor 15 stunden von ihm gelesen er
will jetzt nicht mehr ging es tablets
mit schießen er will sich jetzt als
einfacher abgeordneter einsortieren und
er würde jetzt erstmal die füße still er
hat gesagt er will nicht mehr gegen das
establishment antreten genau an der
street art arbeit und deswegen sagt
seien alle engstes umfeld uns jetzt ganz
klar die übersetzung davon ist er tritt
aber sofort an wenn es nicht mehr das
establishment entscheidet sondern die
breite der partei also die schlagzeile
kann ich dir versichern die kommt nicht
von uns wieder greifen wo ich mir
ausgedacht sondern die kommt tatsächlich
genau daher wo es im von wo es im text
drin steht nämlich aus friedrich merz
dementiert auf twitter das ist na ja
dann nein das ist das ist das ja auch
teilweise perfide spiel der politik
dementiert es nicht er dementiert das
nicht das ist ein es liest sich wie ein
dementi aber es ist genau das gegenteil
er sagt wir haben einen gewählten
parteivorsitzenden
und ich unterstütze seine bemühungen
eine koalition mit fdp und grünen zu
bauen übersetzung wenn das scheitert
unterstütze ich ihn nicht mehr derzeit
stellt sich die frage nach
parteivorsitz nicht heißt derzeit nicht
aber vielleicht schon morgen und dann
bin ich bereit ist also ein sehr
geschickter umgang mit diesem satz da
steht in keiner weise dass er nicht
antreten würde da steht nur drin dass
armin laschet jetzt noch irgendwie die
chance hat etwas zu erreichen wovon du
ja auch sagt es wird halt nicht
funktionieren trotzdem bin ich ehrlich
gesagt diese taktiererei
etwas unsympathischer das dominiert das
gesamte geschehen bei der bei der union
derzeit da hat man ein schwer
angeschlagenen parteivorsitzenden einen
kanzlerkandidaten der dann aber seine
deals durchdrückt in der fraktion in dem
ralf rinke aus noch mal für eine
übergangsfrist
fraktionsvorsitzender werden dahinter
steht eigentlich dass man wahrscheinlich
am ende des oktober einen neuen
vorsitzenden braucht dann muss man einen
auswahlprozess starben dann sollen aber
nicht alle gleichzeitig aus dem bus
springen und sagen ich will und dann
braucht man einen parteitag und dann
muss der neue parteivorsitzende
möglicherweise daneben auch nach dem
fraktionsvorsitz greifen um und
eigentlich das gegenteil was die bürger
gerade interessiert abschluss hier auch
einfach gerade kein das genau all die
die irgendwie die gesichter dieses
scheiterns jetzt auch grad sind alle an
ihren stühlen geben und noch mal eine
schlagzeile rein schmeiße ich will es
noch mal darauf wollen ja nicht halb so
häufig hinaus also dieses dieses
taktieren mit irgendwelchen botschaften
zu sagen ja ich will eigentlich nicht
gegen sex das tablet aber wenn das
anders kommt dann trete ich doch wieder
an dann hinterher aber zu sagen ich bin
aber trotzdem loyal zu haben die lasche
die leute wollen endlich mal ganz klare
gerade unverbogenen leute die sagen ich
will dass ich trete an oder ich will es
nicht und ich trete nicht an
also ich glaube die leute wollen genau
nicht die wollen disziplin anscheinend
sehen darf keine menschliche regungen
zeigen und dann wird man kanzler milli
wahlkampf gelernt wie silvia breher
glaube ich beste stimmergebnis carsten
linnemann drittbestes erststimmen
ergebnis das sind ja echte mensch aber
das kanzleramt urlaub so gut dass er gar
keine regung gegeben und alles neu aber
auch die rau gehört dass er merkel
gehalten wurde oder so gebracht haben
aber ich glaub schon noch an echte
menschen unten lindemann oder eine
brille oder eine sehr abkühle die sind
nicht erste reihe aber warum nicht das
sind die gleich weil sie so menschlich
sony oder vielleicht weil die partei
noch nicht im erneuerungsprozess ist
weil das erst noch kommt und deswegen
ist das für mich jetzt und übergangs
theater was da veranstaltet wird aus das
muss noch einmal kannst du dich noch
einmal kurz strecken befördert dann
irgendwie zusammen für also kann man
gott der abschlussrunde zu dem thema
wäre der perfekte cdu-vorsitzender die
perfekten der cdu vorsitzenden jens
spahn
keine präferenz und keine präferenz und
was gab es für werde desto für die cdu
ich glaube das erst müssen die
mitglieder entscheiden und deswegen
finde ich die idee einer urwahl spannend
und richtig ich glaube nur wir müssen
jetzt endlich mal aufhören über
personalien zu diskutieren sondern uns
auf die inhalte konzentrieren greift was
meinst du meine ganz steile these ich
glaube dass friedrich merz sehr viel hat
vom markus söder nämlich einen
kompletten gestaltungs überdruck im
innern markus söder und friedrich merz
können sich nicht leiden beide werfen
sich gegenseitig vor nur ein programm zu
haben nämlich sich selbst und genau das
diesen gestaltungswillen braucht man
jetzt klare ansagen zu machen und nicht
zu sagen wo kann ich in den gremien
deals machen und die nordrhein westfalen
verschieben klare ansagen deshalb glaube
ich dass friedrich merz unter
gestalterischen und unter
polarisierenden gesichtspunkten
eigentlich der bessere wäre und dann
können sich alle daran abarbeiten so
kurz können sich bildredakteure fasten
haben das glaubst du auf gar keinen fall
sparen auf gar kein feines ich gebe
meine stimme dafür ab zu sagen wer ist
auf gar keinen fall werden darf und
dafür eintrat das ist aber nicht die
frage ich habe in der hand und andere
antwort gemacht und ich möchte auf darf
einsparen ich bleibe weil friedrich merz
das habe ich am anfang nicht sparen
[Musik]